almost every day marshall ringquest
visits schools in great and south africa
brayton is part of the transition town
initiative
these are towns all over the world that
want to become completely carbon neutral
and sustainable
he shows the children how growing their
own vegetables saves money and helps the
environment our main goal as return
season town is to
to reduce our carbon footprint as far as
possible
that's like i would say we're still
busy making a kind of a foundation on
john's season just getting people
inspired to live more green to recycle
to reduce the carbon footprint
rodney cupido is the school principal he
wants to install a large solar power
facility here reducing co2 emissions
plays one role among many by installing
solar panels on our big roof we will be
able to earn money by selling the
electricity and with that money we can
buy books we can pay for the transports
taking the learner home and also getting
the learner to school and that will
improve education and quality teaching
at our school
some 8 000 people living in greyton and
the surrounding communities take part in
the transition town initiative one
aspect of the project is to bridge
differences between the prosperous
central town and poor outlying areas
where many lack money and prospects
it wasn't easy for people to actually
get to um get it with each other but i
think now that they're actually working
together with john season there's some
more bond with each other where they can
actually share ideas in terms of our
knowledge of our people and
so to call what people are
to convince more people here to commit
themselves to climate and environmental
protection the trash to treasure
festival takes place every year right on
the rubbish dump
children make eco bricks out of plastic
waste by stuffing empty bottles with
scraps of plastic the bottles can
actually be used to build affordable
housing
walls made out of the bottles are well
insulated and that saves energy
joseph stodgel started the trash to
treasure festival
we're showing people how they can use
the great majority of everything they
throw away on a daily basis
to aid community resilience to grow food
to insulate their homes and a big part
of this is the eco brick this simple
technology of using a plastic bottle
stuffing your plastic trash into it and
and really sequestering that carbon that
would otherwise be released into the
environment
grayton has many plans for the future
but all the people here believe that in
the long term their town will no longer
be damaging the climate or the
environment
you